- [Instructor] We're asked
to graph the equation
y is equal to one-half times x minus six
times x plus two.
So like always, pause this video
and take out some graph paper
or even try to do it on
a regular piece of paper
and see if you can graph this equation.
All right now, let's work
through this together.
There's many different ways that you could
attempt to graph it.
May be the most basic is
try out a bunch of x values
and a bunch of y values and
try to connect the curve
that connects all of those dots.
But let's try to see if
we can get the essence
of this graph without
doing that much work.
The key realization here without
even having to do the math
is if I multiply this out,
if I multiplied x minus
six times x plus two,
I'm going to get a quadratic.
I'm going to get x-squared,
plus something, plus something else.
And so this whole thing
is going to be a parabola.
We are graphing a quadratic equation.
Now a parabola you might remember
can intersect the x-axis multiple times.
So let's see if we can find out
where this intersects the x-axis.
And the form that it's in,
it's in factored form already,
it makes it pretty straightforward
for us to recognize
when does y equal zero?
Which are going to be the
times that we're intersecting
the x-axis.
And then from that, we'll
actually be able to find
the coordinates of the vertex
and we're going to be able
to get the general shape
of this curve which is
going to be a parabola.
So let's think about it.
When does y equal zero?
Well to solve that we just
have to figure out when,
if we want to know when y equals zero,
then we have to solve for
when does this expression equal zero?
So let's just solve the equation.
One half times x minus six,
times x plus two is equal to zero.
Now in previous videos we've
talked about this idea.
If I have the product of multiple things
and it needs to be equal to zero,
the only way that's going to happen
is if one or more of these things
are going to be equal to zero.
Well one half is one-half,
it's not going to be equal to zero.
But x minus six could be equal to zero.
So if x minus six is equal to zero,
then that would make this equation true.
Or if x plus two is equal to zero,
that would also make this equation true.
So the x values that
satisfy either of these
would make y equal zero
and those would be places
where our curve is
intersecting the x-axis.
So what x value makes
x minus six equal zero?
Well you could add six to both sides,
you're probably able to
do that in your head,
and you get x is equal to six.
Or you subtract two from both sides here
and you get x is equal to,
these cancel out,
you get x is equal to negative two.
These are the two x values
where y will be equal to zero.
You can substitute it back
into our original equation.
If x is equal to six,
then this right over here is
going to be equal to zero,
and then y is going to be equal to zero.
If x is equal to negative two,
then this right over here is
going to be equal to zero,
and y would be equal to zero.
So we know that our parabola
is going to intersect
the x-axis at x equals
negative two right over there,
and x is equal to six.
These are our x-intercepts.
So given this, how do we
figure out the vertex?
Well the key idea here is to recognize
that your axis of
symmetry for your parabola
is going to sit right between
your two x-intercepts.
So what is the midpoint between,
or what is the average
of six and negative two?
Well, you could do that in your head.
Six plus negative two is
four divided by two is two.
Let me do that.
So I'm just trying to find the
midpoint between the point,
let's use a new color.
So I'm trying to find the midpoint
between the point negative two comma zero
and six comma zero.
Well the midpoint, those are just
the average of the coordinates.
The average of zero and zero
is just going to be zero,
it's going to sit on the x-axis.
But then the midpoint
of negative two and six
or the average negative
two plus six over two.
Well let's see, that's four over two,
that's just going to be two,
so two comma zero.
And you see that there.
You could have done that
without even doing the math.
You say okay,
if I want to go right in between the two,
I want to be two away from each of them.
And so just like that,
I could draw an axis
of symmetry for my parabola.
So my vertex is going to sit
on that axis of symmetry.
And so how do I know what the y value is?
Well I can figure out,
I can substitute back
in my original equation,
and say well what is y equal
when x is equal to two?
Because remember the vertex
has a coordinate x equals two.
It's going to be two comma something.
So let's go back, let's see what y equals.
So y will equal to one-half times,
we're going to see when x equals two,
so two minus six,
times two plus two.
Let's see, this is negative four,
this is positive four.
Negative four times four is negative 16.
So it's equal to one-half
times negative 16,
which is equal to negative eight.
So our vertex when x is equal to two,
y is equal to negative eight.
And so our vertex is going
to be right over here
two common negative eight.
And now we can draw the general shape
of our actual parabola.
It's going to look something like,
once again this is a hand-drawn sketch,
so take it with a little
bit of a grain of salt,
but it's going to look
something like this.
And it's going to be symmetric
around our axis of symmetry.
That's why it's called
the axis of symmetry.
This art program I have,
there's a symmetry tool,
but I'll just use this and there you go.
That's a pretty good sketch
of what this parabola is
or what this graph is going
to look like which it is,
an upward-opening parabola.